public outcry is growing after recent
revelations about how technology giants
like Facebook and Google collect and use
our data the new book exploding data
reclaiming our cybersecurity in the
digital age highlights the many dangers
of modern technology and data collection
author Michael Chertoff former secretary
of homeland security under president
george w bush writes this in the book we
have always been worried that Big
Brother might force his way into our
home but Big Brother need not beat down
the door we are currently rolling out
the red carpet to him Chertoff is
currently executive chairman and
co-founder of the security consulting
firm the Chertoff group good morning
welcome we're glad to have you here
what do you mean rolling out the red
carpet we are actually surveilling
ourselves we're doing a lot of the
collection that we used to imagine would
be the government as individuals we go
around we take selfies we photograph
each other we upload things to the
internet other things are being
collected on us for example video
cameras locational data on our cell
phone and all of this winds up in what
they call the cloud which is the servers
which maintain all of this data and so
the person who operates the server can
look all across these various uploads
and construct a very accurate picture of
everything we do every day and that is
why we have actually become little
brother in the face of Big Brother you
actually that you argue that the privacy
ship has essentially already sailed and
that it's really autonomy we should
worry about explain that concept privacy
means to most of us keeping things
hidden behind closed doors or a private
conversation and what I've seen over the
last several years is so much data is
generated by us unwittingly that the
idea that we're going to keep these
behind closed doors really has become
almost quaint
so now the question is what happens when
the data is generated do we have some
control over and that I think is where
the battleground is in terms of our
freedom because if people have a 100%
view of everything that we do all the
time then the ability to manipulate us
and coerce us becomes a real issue okay
but it is the wild wild west out there
what control
do we have over our data that we're
putting out there so I think there are
two things I suggest we need to think
about one is what can we do as
individuals and part of that is being
mindful when we do generate data if
we're asked to give our email address or
to share locational data we've got to
make a mindful decision is it worth
doing the second thing is I do think we
need to have the courts and the
government do some weighing of what the
balance water be in terms of data
control we now have platforms that are
so vast that they really almost
monopolies and the condition of
participating often is surrendering your
data and the question is where do we
want to put some limits on that and say
no people have a right to say no without
sacrificing your ability to access the
platform and of course what comes to
mind er black about actors and nefarious
actors right who want to steal that data
is the government currently prepared or
doing enough to protect American
citizens from nefarious actors you know
the government is making progress but
the challenge is that most of the
infrastructure is in private hands and
I'll give you a good example we have the
Internet of Things we now have smart
refrigerators smart baby cameras those
things are often not built with any
security in mind and that means they can
be hijacked by bad actors and then that
becomes the portal to enter into the
network and take the network over so we
need to start to put some standards in
place about how to manufacture and
deploy these devices so there is a
security element to it and we can
protect ourselves so do you think we're
going to continue to see more battles
like we saw between Apple and the FBI as
far as taking that data that that had
been stolen and accessing it why are
there going to be challenges about how
do we balance for example law
enforcement Sneed for access with a need
to protect data against bad actors to
encryption we're going to see battles
about which law governs is it the US law
is if the Chinese law is if the Russian
laws if the EU law because the global
environment in which data operates
doesn't have borders but our laws do
have borders so these are all challenges
in terms of taking
our laws and our policies into the 21st
century and where does in terms of any
regulations where do you think it best
is applied is it through laws through
Congress which is sometimes been a
little bit behind on this thing or as a
former member of the executive branch is
this something that's done through
executive agencies I mean some of it can
be done through administrative agencies
you have the FTC for example or the FCC
have certain regulatory powers
so does DHS it would be great if
Congress could do something in this area
but you're quite right they have not
always been successful in doing it the
courts are gonna play a role you know
there's been discussion to the Supreme
Court today the Supreme Court is
actually beginning to look at this set
of issues there was a case just a few
weeks ago call carpenter having to do
with the ability to access locational
cell phone data all right and you could
see the Justice is beginning to wrestle
with the very issues we're talking about
in the book how do we control the data
once it's been generated so I think the
courts are actually going to play a
major role in this
finally can I just ask you since you're
the former head of the Department of
Homeland Security what's going what do
you think should be going on with
reuniting these children with their
families well I think we ought to
rewrite the children as quickly as
possible
I don't know how they've distributed
them but it seems to me it's a big
priority to make sure that every kid is
accounted for and then returned to the
family you know bureaucracy what's the
fastest way to get and complicate a
problem like this moving because it's
clearly not moving very fast well I tell
you the courts are actually pretty have
a lot of capability in terms of
prompting the agencies and I'm sure at
this point there is a strong desire to
get this thing done as quickly as
possible the difficulties if you didn't
front load the process by telling where
people were going to go and keeping
track of them it does become difficult
after the fact and I'm sure they're
working hard to do it and I'm sure the
judges are gonna really you know kind of
jab now these reunifications are not
happening fast enough michael chertoff
thank you so much great to have you on
set